I'm planning on running for by the way
you have to really understand what he's
saying matter of fact I dare you to
fully understand what he's saying go
ahead and play the clip watch us here
that's the doctor that's a fantastic
Advantage this is my favorite of the
year I was just wondering uh Mr
President uh will you be uh taking part
in the Easter egg rolls uh after
planning on after 2025. I plan on at
least three or four more Easter egg
rolls at least three or four more maybe
five maybe five maybe maybe six what the
hell are you saying that uh that you
would be uh taking part in uh our
upcoming election
you know being the the you know the guy
who's pushed them out come on
I plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet all right
either roll an egg or push one out in
our upcoming election
you know being the the you know the guy
who's
he just said it without saying it with
an egg coming out whatever the hell that
yeah how's he pushing that egg out
[Music]
maybe he identifies as a chicken you
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with that yeah I'm not I'm
not I just wish one time one person
interviewing just stops and goes like
this hey uh I'm sorry Mr President what
the hell are you talking about say what
buddy yeah yeah exactly nobody ever
checks him Trump was always yelled at by
Jim Acosta and everybody not one but he
didn't talk like this before I've heard
him give speech it's getting worse no
I've heard him give speeches where
you're kind of like okay okay he's got
some stuff that's solid he he didn't
talk like this this is recent and Pat
notis but but it's gonna be he's gonna
be 82 right by the next election if he
gets realized he'll be 86 years old
has to be a concern of course it is if
you can push an egg out at 86. you gotta
respect it you should be president man
uh yeah it's uh he's doing this look he
he successfully ran a campaign from his
basement for the most part of course and
you know again the Democrat let's see
you know I love them hate them right
they they tend to do messaging and
campaigns and communication well because
they stick to it right they they don't
tend to Splinter and so I think his
strategists are basically saying look
why jump in the fight right now hey take
take all the time you want right you
don't you're in the the White House
already you don't need to announce yet
and he could push us off and while he's
doing that he's kind of freezing out the
other options like Newsom and these
others right so right so we've got
you know we've got a really interesting
situation here where I think both sides
are kind of getting locked in to before
we even get to the uh the primary which
shit's about to get it but it's gonna
get so dirty and I think this next one's
going to be nasty so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]